lugan Nate here with the AL Boys YouTube
channel and for the next 4 days we're
exploring Alaska's Frozen rainforests
we're camping in freezing temperatures
hunting for our food discovering crashed
military planes flying over glaciers and
having a great
[Music]
time
they turn our homes into
lashes we fled out the back door we ran
towards the
city
city still not all this
conrete up been and causing the
outskirts where we
sit sleeping the back
seat
oh
[Music]
all right guys welcome to Goose Davis
Alaska this is a small community at the
mouth of Glacier Bay National Park and
about a 20-minute flight west of Juno
and like most places in Alaska the only
way you can get in and out of this
community is by plane or boat there's no
roads out side of this community just
slightly over 600 people live here in
gust Davis Davis Davis Davis okay it's
not gust Davis it's gust Davis I'm going
to make that mistake a lot in this
video oh looks like we got a little
place to eat let's go get some
lunch all right go
on what did you guys that's a that's a
big wolf this restaurant is owned and
operated by the school and kids come
here for Class Credit to learn work
skills and
stuff all right we actually got to meet
the principal of the school and half the
high school students they were all
really
[Applause]
nice W in
life I think this might be the town
supermarket it's nice being in places
where you don't need to lock everything
up this is the only Market in town so
everyone gets their groceries from here
sumers SA
six bucks for 1 gallon of milk it's not
bad it's a good price Nathan lost one of
his gloves in the airport so we got to
go get a new pair of
gloves here try try your hand in you
like those mhm all right we get
those this is for our cooking stove
uhhuh well we got lunch camping fuel
snacks I think it's time to go find a
campsite oh there's some ducks down in
the river yeah we're definitely going
duck hunting later
[Applause]
on in the summertime a lot of tourists
come here to fish for salmon or to go to
the national park but once the fall Hits
it gets so
quiet this is the ferry terminal this is
how everyone gets their cars and a lot
of their big
supplies I can see a whole bunch of
Canadian geese right over there across
the
way there we
go what is wrong with
that oh that is destroyed my Goose call
completely fell apart in the bag that's
what I get for buying a cheap Goose call
going to try riding across this sand a
little bit see this is why we brought
the fat
bikes there's a whole bunch of
sucks oh I must have said something to
offend
him tell you what this is a lovely spot
think you want to camp here Nate yeah I
think Nate's ready to
camp
we just got finished setting up the tent
and I heard some Canadian geese just
over here I brought some absolute
artillery shells these are 3 and 1/2
inch double
bees
oh just jumped two mards off this
River over here in the grass Nathan
quick here comes some Canadian
Keys I've already shot twice and missed
twice so I'm on a hot streak oh
my all
right well it is cold and I've got a
hungry little boy I think it's time to
get some dinner made you'll hop into
your bag get warmed up you got it I have
this little tripod I used to prop my
camera up so I can film and the leg fell
off somewhere oh that is going to make
filming very challenging going try
sticking my camera in Nathan's
boot
look at that big moon that's rising up
over the horizon even though it's
bitterly cold it's still
gorgeous
do not spill it in the in the tent you
got
that that is hard to beat isn't
that that is so
good oh it is so cold out here every
everything's icing up look at all the
frost on this bag weather forecast said
the low was going to be in the 30s I
don't think that was the
truth do you like a hot water
bottle
yes oh I think it's time to get into
this bed it's
cold
yeah hey bud are you warm yeah you want
to watch a movie or something yeah we
got a chocolate covered hazelnuts we're
going to eat while we watch a
movie well the sun's about to rise R and
I'm going to go do some duck hunting but
oh it is so cold everything is covered
in Frost look at my
bicycle oh look at that all right Nathan
I'll be
back all right guys the sun's just
barely popping up and I'm going to sneak
over to this River that's right by the
tent we saw a bunch of ducks there
yesterday and I bet they're going to be
back if I'm really
quiet
[Music]
there we go that's a beautiful female M
duck right
there hey yeah
Nathan Nathan look what I got you got
dog nice look at
that
oh look at
this I did a time lapse last night is
what my GoPro looks like
now all right I got to go ahead and
clean this away from the
campsite this bird is just covered in
ice there we go two beautiful duck
breasts the meat is this dark red color
because there's so little fat in it duck
has about 25 % of the fat of
domesticated chickens as a general rule
wild meat has much less fat and is much
lower in cholesterol than domestic meat
well these will go really well with
dinner tonight well we survived the
night we shot a duck now it's time to
make some breakfast Nathan you want
chocolate chip pancakes
yeah another reason you heat up the
water bottles and put them in your
sleeping bag it's cuz if you don't your
all your water will be ice in the
morning it's a big pain in the butt to
melt ice once it forms in a plastic
bottle good
yeah well since my tripod broke I have
to lean my selfie stick up against this
bench or I hold it between my legs it's
always a challenge isn't
it yeah
sure there we
go David you like this you get breakf
and bed and get to watch some cartoons
wait hey Nathan you got some chocolate
on your your hand there wait that that's
chocolate right tell me it's chocolate
tell me it's chocolate tell me it's
chocolate
Nathan well now that we got food in us I
think we should get the bikes ready and
go and explore the area a little bit
more and among other things I hear that
there's a large plane crash site nearby
and I want to do a little hiking and see
if we can't find it come on let's go do
some
exploring
me and Nathan realized our butts are a
little bit more sore than we thought
yeah a pedal standing up it's just just
do that for a
while peaches peaches peaches Peach
peaches you guys having a good day oh
yeah your principal uh flagged me down
and asked me to speak in at career day
you think I should do that 100% all
right we met those high school kids and
their principal while eating at the
Fox's Den yesterday the principal talked
me into doing a career day Zoom meeting
so uh we're going to we're going to do
that here in a few
weeks
hell all right we're going to swing by
the store and pick up some supplies not
having my tripod is driving me crazy so
I am determined to try to Jerry ring
something let's see got a/4 in 20 3/4
bolt there we
go oh
hello okay okay now I need a plastic
lid thank
you okay I'm going to build my
tripod drill the hole with this
thing we got a tripod
again the tripod
works
doing good back there uhhuh
good do you see a
trail all right we're going to do a
little hike through the rainforest gust
Davis is at the top of the Alaskan
Panhandle and this whole part of Alaska
is temperate rainforest look at this
everything just gets covered in Moss to
the
ground
bench oh look at
this piece of the
airplane I
see that's like a piece of some rubber
right there well let's see if we can
find the rest of the
plane this crazy look at all the wires
in
here I think that's the part of the
engine right there here's one of the
tires there you go there's another chunk
of engine right there this is the
wreckage of a DC3 it's a passenger cargo
plane it crashed in 1957 while it was
trying to take off from the gustus
airport it's a pretty good siiz twin
engine
plane this DC3 was used by the US
military you can see where it says Air
National Guard across the
top
oh you think I
should yeah just watch out for the sharp
bits look at
this I don't think this plan went down
maybe
you can see the Air Force symbol really
good over
[Music]
here says Pennsylvania Air National
Guard right there across the
top you hungry Nathan I think that means
we need to get going and go get some
lunch
well I've got a little boy whose bottom
needs a bench and his stomach needs a
burger I'm so
hungry there you
go look at
this you're bottom this is just a really
warm and friendly community so much so
in fact we just got invited to a
Halloween
[Laughter]
party oh marshmallow
here stop that stomach rumbling the
child will hear you Gabe was definitely
not gone you liking that more good we
better get you to bed though okay all
right all right you snuggle in my bag
while I go and get everything warmed up
okay there we go my
tripod okay it was a bit cold last night
and I want Nathan to go camping with me
again so I got to take care of him so I
am pulling out all the stops I've got a
ton of hand warmers here we are going to
put them in this cloth bag
here
there you go ready for some
reason oh there's some ice in my
water okay I want it's time for some
dinner how about some cranberry couscous
and
duck got dried cranberries and
couscous
wa there's an earthquake going on right
now that must have been a pretty good
one first I thought I was just getting a
little dizzy but then I was like nope
nope the ground is shaking yeah that's
Alaska for
you
[Music]
oh these duck breasts smell so
good cranberry couscous and Mard duck
breast nice Andy Nathan do you want some
duck
yeah
here fresh duck is so
good that so good that duck breast was
better than any steak I've ever eaten
that was so
good oh man that tasted
fabulous need to go do the dishes
now
how you doing Nathan are you warm huh
well it's late and it's cold I'm going
to get in my sleeping bag and I will see
you guys in the morning well good
morning it's a lot warmer this morning
notice that there isn't frost on
everything we had clouds come in last
night and that keeps it from getting
bitterly cold the coldest days are
always the clear ones but uh I've got to
hurry up and get some breakfast going
we're going to fly into the national
park this
morning oh my bottom
sore the duks and geese must have known
we're leaving cuz they're just all over
our campsite right
now me and Nathan are headed to the
airport and we're leaving GIS but we're
not going straight back to Juno a
charter is going to pick us up and we're
going to take a sightseeing tour through
Glacier Bay National Park which is
supposed to be one of the most gorgeous
national parks in the
country okay it was touch and go but it
looks like the Pilot's going to get our
bikes onto that little Cessna I'm
impressed you want to go in
[Music]
first
hey I heard you want to leave this place
where we grew all this old time just put
it all
behind remember you and I would always
find somewhere to hide when we were kids
so we could see and hear the water run
the river's going to cry when you're
[Music]
going where will you go won't you miss
the on you know I'll be here hanging on
waiting for you
come seems like
time as a wave passing by leave from
well guys we had a great time and I hope
you enjoyed watching this video if you
want to see more videos from the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel make sure to click
subscribe I'll see you next video If you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for
watching